I'm Hollywood gay theist the angry gay
Pope I take donations to fight the cult
of Scientology at patreon.com slash
angry gay Pope come on you guys the
truth patrol is here you're not selling
anything you're just wasting your young
lives wasted your love young lives on
the boulevard rewards for El run
there's no time 13 o clock
[Music]
hey everybody its episode 80 kind of a
special edition yeah we've already
recorded this one actually yes we're
just we're just uh recording the intro
right now it was good show
we got the angry gay Pope's to come back
again give us an update on what's going
on yeah in the crazy cult of Scientology
yeah he answered news stories and talked
about some of the new videos they did
but yes this is his third appearance on
the show and always a really good really
fun guest to have her fun time even
though you know we have to cut out goes
wild you know he's you know yeah he's a
GP that's that yeah he does you know
that's that's why we love having him on
the show he's there and after his I hope
I didn't say too much you know I've got
all these pending legal stuff and the
cult wants to know this and that this
and that so his only secret missions so
you know he tries to keep a lot of the
stuff that he does underneath the wraps
but then he comes and talks about it
anyway yeah cuz here's the thing like I
guess I'm not a big advocate of like
conspiracy theories in general like
99.9% of them are [ __ ] but ones
about the Church of Scientology I
believe that [ __ ] because one I used to
work there not for the church
specifically but it was owned by them
yeah and I would not put anything past
him and look at this [ __ ] they're doing
like um angry gay Pope for example he
has a video and he posted I believe it
was in December of 2017 about how this
supposed church has license plate
photographing cameras hidden in trees on
a public street that is a public street
yeah that is so illegal why do they need
pictures of people's license plates that
are driving past their [ __ ] building
they can shoot their enemies yeah unless
they're [ __ ] stalkers and they're
gonna look your [ __ ] up now that make
sure their enemies aren't running buy a
watch and then they're paranoid yeah
that's what I mean it's like something
out of out of like the the Cold War
there in a Cold War mentality
they're totally crazy right yeah it's a
trip it's the weirdest thing ever like I
like if someone just told it to me and I
didn't see like evidence of it and I
didn't
know them I would think they were making
it up yeah and because we had a GP on
you will see comments in the comment
sections from OSA agents which is their
version of like the year the SS yeah
that's like this yeah like their secrets
yeah and then the one that they usually
do is some of that's it unsub this is
against the freedom of religion and they
go on about religion and the sent ology
is not a religion it's just not no no it
is a cause and a scam it was what it is
it was from the very beginning designed
to be an alternative to psychiatry or
psychology and then later on l ron
hubbard wanted to be wanted to be tax
exempt and they turned it into a
religion yeah so they wouldn't have to
pay attention right and exactly why they
did it and it's a UFO cult basically you
a brainwashing Marxist style UFO cults
like something out of North Korea but in
a weird way Ultra capitalist and
corporatist yeah because all of their
all of their jargon is very corporatist
you having and like I said I've read
enough of l ron hubbard [ __ ] when I
worked for this stupid company their
water I don't know that dude is straight
corporate very generic very much super
super mundane they think it's you guys
yeah man because they call ot powers
which is like powers of the mind ESP
telekinesis everything that a Jedi can
do even like total control over the
space-time continuum you know they they
believe all that how they all deny some
grace can totally time try everyone yeah
they will deny this but in their ot
material which has all been published
you can see exactly as they go up
through the OT levels of what they're
trying to do yeah their total nutcases
yeah and you'd have to pay money to go
up through the level which is actually
that was something that Aleister Crowley
tried to do with the Golden Dawn yeah is
to me yeah so I kind of think yeah you
pay to move up in occult levels and
there's some crossover between Aleister
Crowley and l ron hubbard there you know
l ron hubbard was inspired by Kovac well
also pyramid scheme pyramid schemes in
our religion when they get in a comment
section and start crying about you know
freedom of religion of the rights were
is not a well and the other thing that
annoys me about those kind of comments
is just because you have freedom of
religion doesn't mean other people can't
criticize you we also have freedom to
not subscribe to religions and to
criticize yours because they are dumb it
is as if Avon became or Amway became a
religion I would say and we're actually
actually I'm a GP mentioned on the
interview right it's about like
corporation corporate mind power
providing slow religion and the funny
thing about it is I was going to do I
actually wasn't going to do one of my
current event news stories on this
episode just because the interview ran a
little bit long but then out of
curiosity I was like I'm at a Google
Scientology and see if there was
anything any news stories about
Scientology that came out in the past
week right and of course there was so
right here on The Associated Press dated
February 23rd 2018 Columbia South
Carolina a former employee of a South
Carolina chiropractor says he sexually
assaulted her and tried to convert her
to Scientology so evidently the woman
who's making the accusations she's just
known as Jane Doe she's 25 years old she
worked in this chiropractic office and
said chiropractor Joseph Barton
evidently sexually assaulted this woman
and made sexual advances toward her that
were unwanted then she was fired and he
also allegedly said outright that he was
going to convert her to Scientology and
like it was some kind of [ __ ] threat
or something and so yeah so she says so
she's suing and because that's really
illegal you guys even like the company
that I worked for you had to like sign a
paper at the beginning that said we're
totally not allowed we're not gonna
convert you it's fine and stuff like
that even though they kind of subtly did
okay now
sexual assault you guys you gotta
testify she he's touching a booty right
yeah or something touches something okay
don't touch yeah yeah don't sass what
the [ __ ] especially your [ __ ] boss
yeah you know I mean because it's well
they have the power to fire yeah yeah
man you have no money no so that's
shitty not only is he a chiropractor
which 90% of those are [ __ ] woo
Meister's anyway like oh let me crack
there
and also all your [ __ ] asthma and all
that [ __ ] although I do admit when I was
in high school I went to a water man
that dude popped my back good you're
flapping your back and so he knocks over
claim that's always clean yes yeah
that's just like physical therapy that's
there's nothing wrong with that
I'm just talking about the ones that are
all into this
oh you're I'm aligning your chakras and
all that other yeah and most of the very
this will cure your cancer right it's
like and it seems like a lot of them
have gone like that so I don't know if
this douches like one of those this
alleged ish sorry but um he's it's nice
colleges he's gotta be at least
partially a douche but yeah so this
alleged use not only I see a
chiropractor is probably some [ __ ]
mystical well yeah what's that thing
with the Chinese people do you smell
stuff what's that called
oh they having to smell stuff yes I'm a
therapy something like yeah I think
that's what's called it like it's
showing up in these dead malls these
Chinese go in there and they do things
to you it's supposed to help your team I
think they you smelled them off I do see
how they do I think like massage on your
back and that you know that Eliza smells
are supposed to like improve your mood
and stuff but I don't think that the
effect is all that great right you know
what I mean so it's not like oh
everything is awesome now they're all
cinnamon buns we gotta do do a show on
like the origins of all that kind of
stuff like a Roma therapy that would be
fun actually so yeah so anyway so this
woman is suing this alleged jackhole oh
and this is good too I forgot to mention
this this guy says he says he's a
Scientologist and this allows him to
quote-unquote sense emotional
disturbances in people yeah he's one
with the force I guess so
so I guess he sensed that she would be
alright with him like sexually
assaulting but here's the thing though I
can sense emotional disturbance most
people can it's not a client weird
that's not a client that's just part of
being a human yes with empathy yeah
which I realize that some people don't
have but you know most people do to some
extent you can tell when someone's upset
or you know yeah like I when the animals
are upset I could tell women yes suppose
you can tell like their pets and things
like that you can
upset is language yeah so I don't see
why that's like super [ __ ] special
but anyway yeah so that was that was the
news story today so we'll be following
that's cuz I was just always so I can
claim make all these claims about normal
abilities well it's because they don't
interact with normal people so they
don't know what normal people are
capable of so they somehow think that
they're better is the first thing that
the first thing they teachers the
communications course as if you don't
know how to talk yes and obviously and I
had to take that course when I work
there yeah and obviously okay
Scientologists maybe not the ones that
like live in the normal world and stuff
but like the ones that have been brought
up in it the ones that are closer and
stuff like that they come off very much
like robots in human suits yeah and it's
really sad to me that they have to be
told how to interact in a normal human
fashion because apparently they don't
know how to do that yeah I'll tell you
what one time I was walking down Newbury
Street this was down in Boston and a
girl came out of a building and says
won't you come in for a free personality
test and I said person what said that
what's that for it was just out of the
army you know yeah what's that for you
to find out what kind of person you are
so I know what kind of person I am I
mean I'm right here
oh whatever you know and and that's the
test right there
if you don't know a kind of person you
are you'll go with them
they're looking for somebody who doesn't
know what kind of person they are and
some stranger at a street obviously
isn't going to tell you well they're
gonna give you a test yeah so you can
find out so they can tell you what kind
of person you are and you're the kind of
person that needs to give them somebody
yes this is a good thing this is why I'm
kind of glad that I'm just like a Crabby
[ __ ] because anytime like somebody
approached me like hey you want this no
no I don't want it go away
yeah I'm just very much like yeah help
me if you can't help me I don't want
anything you have I don't want it just
leave me alone all right so that's kind
of our introduction and so now we're
going to accede the floor to the anger
gave up and once she gets rolling I
tried you know good though I'm like
cutting now hold on you know EGP we need
to cut for a break tonight
oh okay just kept on going all right you
can't control anything so I just let it
ride yeah you just know this is a show
of Tom and Jenny just let it ride he's a
great guest yeah he really is okay so
enjoy the interview and we will be back
at the end to wrap things up and do our
regular stuff and so here it is who we
have with us right now is of course the
world-famous AGP but also known as the
angry gay Pope and just to give the
audience in case you're not a regular
listener to give us a little bit of
background on who AGP is ATP is a member
of anonymous he's I guess you could say
he's one of the main members in a small
crack team of special operatives out of
a cult
Scientology how I met AGP is I actually
met AGP online he's got an awesome
channel called yeah and this this
channel that he has is absolutely
mesmerizing
it's just hours and hours and hours of
entertainment and education about this
cult and we also makes them weaker
entertains and education turbulator
exactly and it makes them weaker because
you get to see them doing what they do
and what they do is [ __ ] weird yeah
years later tears streaming down their
face explaining something to Leah Remini
or Karen Dylan carrier or some other ex
it's like what they're doing right now
yeah and he's got him all in good
playlist like he has funny videos and a
playlist scary videos in a playlist just
zany [ __ ] educational stuff so this
this is like one of my favorite YouTube
channels I would just put angry gatepost
channel on and just let it play all day
long I sit there and just watch it go
for something and then screen the Brady
Bunch list of other things the more you
click on my videos the more just by the
nature of YouTube it finds you back into
more my videos
yeah and people will like leave it on
binge watch thing they tell me they
binge watch this is like screaming the
tears over their incarcerations like I
would never think this was something you
could be in this watch but fans come up
to the person and say like oh I sit
there every night in bed and watch your
videos and this wife says I just roll
over and don't watch what I listen the
whole time yeah and one of the weird
side effects is that the AGP is actually
made celebrities out of like cult
members and cult guards yeah you know
guys like
and you know like Frank Paulo his videos
are awesome and just you know I think
you called toilet toilet goes into the
other direction too on the opposite end
of the spectrum would be the the ever
handsome mr. Angel pretty much guys like
whatever character we're going to turn
the guards into if they're good-looking
we love no matter what Alerus cuz angels
like this young latin guy he's very good
luck he's very handsome he looks like an
actor and they'll simply from a rich
family - yeah or just kids from rich
families and then they use in this
ridiculous place yeah he'll be standing
outside some kind of you know
Scientology org with his chest out his
chin held high in the air well I'm a
student that is my h-e-b just tell her
how pretty is
insider and keep a smile from breaking
out over there
although noticing that I'm noticing that
they're not really good at controlling
their emotions like they were did you
smile now you probably started blushing
now notice that the Scientologists are
becoming more and more Latin more and
more South American what's going on okay
but the real deal is numerically Russia
really okay you know and they can come
over here and then they take away their
green cards and passports and stuff so
they can't believe they come on a
religious visa so down in clear water
where they own that town and they have a
lot of Scientologists come in for
counseling it's like the mecca of
Scientology I've heard that's really
infested with like Eastern Europeans
Russians because there's just not a lot
of anti-scientology material on the
Internet in their languages so right it
seems like like I said if there's not a
lot of information about Scientology
over there it seems like a really easy
thing especially people that are kind of
desperate reporter different country
with a marketing scheme they just yeah
one leg oh this is written in German and
replace it with another Lego block
that's written in Ukrainian and then the
whole Lego sculpture it was an action
yeah that does seem to be something
there I mean you know that does seem to
be something they're kind of a good at
yeah
now you posted a video a couple weeks
back of rent to skank who the hell was
rent this game with cold guard Alexi
they were arrested basically and the
cops were on the church's side and so
this group of [ __ ] block protesters
strong in the action immediately and
they had a protest really quickly
and we all went there and so when the
church who listens to our emails and
reads because he listens to our cell
phones breathes our emails reached our
cell phone call records they didn't have
enough time to rent proper people to
like randomly walk by and be offended at
us rush by these like quick skanks were
political Hollywood hang about mayor
dwells and you know it probably some
kind of crazy drug problems or whatever
and they paid these people to sit there
on the bench when we all arrived and one
of them which I call the Renaissance and
like dancing like a Niall would shot the
video and like I'm so glad his camera is
better than mine and the camera pulled a
focus from like 6 inches away you can
see her [ __ ] nose hairs those hairs I
know she's like in his face and clearly
like Pro Scientology for no reason and
she has like piercings and stuff which
Scientologists never have they're very
like the Mormons very clean-cut looking
you early seaside told us with tattoos
or piercings and then you know that
probably paid off my guards somewhere or
whatever someone just standing there and
she had some sort of relationship with
the guys on the bench guys on the bench
mole paid off too but they were
surrounded by protesters if you watch
the video you can point out the guy on
that the bike is like a [ __ ] guard bank
guard and he had like he brought
exchanger
he's so used to picking with the police
I am so used to messin interpolated yeah
[Laughter]
so this rendus gang just gets in his
face and babbles weird and then she runs
over and lifts up her top and they like
she runs around the corner she's about
to leave like she runs into me and like
someone says fire magesh li see me from
a third-person perspective instead of
like saying why yeah she said some like
really stupid stuff there and then I
like followed her across the street just
like blasting her being what she is a
paid off skank and that's not my camera
I didn't yeah but it's a very funny
weird video that is like you can't make
it up department you know yeah if
someone said that Donald Trump's gonna
be President other things you'd never
believe it because it's reality is
always more interesting than something
that's constructed in Leslie Star Wars
which is a deeply religious
[Laughter]
documentaries if you call it a
documentary like these videos are a
documentary really but that sounds
boring but you call them reality TV
something in the ng about topless girls
and big brothers flashing around you
know like people if the people know
they're being recorded that can be bad
it's something coming on but also an
effect where if people know they're
being watched their behavior changes so
I keep my camera just dangling around my
tummy which is like I'm so 12 like much
right you can keep spaces and you get
them looking slightly off camera
behaving normally so it is a reality TV
but now there's another kind of reality
TV like the Ruby pumping iron where
everybody knows they're being recorded
so Arnold plays the bad guy also under
place the bad guy move foreigner plays a
good guy
you get the audience to get engaged
something that is really boring like
who's gonna you t contest the biggest
oversized muscle you know here that's a
different kind of reality this is what I
do is kind of a mixture which sometimes
I don't want people to know they're
being recorded like in the Inglewood
idea Lorne the Pasadena ideal or the
Scientology of Beverly Hills mission
things like that it's like hiding in
plain sight this r2d2 Hal 9000 you know
robot from the movie 2001 a space I've
seen watching them but I'm acting like
c-3po someday don't notice that I must
seek to repeal r2d2 a hybrid in my navel
is like the big eyeball it's gonna stare
at them for yeah I notice he has some
new material centered around Inglewood
Inglewood
org and that's a very different org is
that the org and that is a black organ
at it from two locations
who would ideal org which is their large
but ideal org is their large meeting
house for Scientology or the Inglewood
community center which is a like theater
the main part is like a theater room
surrounded by all the other services
that I told you can offer and Eric
Garcetti the mayor and the chief of
police went there for a major deal in
which the Crips and the Bloods like
major Inglewood gangs like bury the
hatchet okay now it had something to do
with the Nation of Islam too didn't it
yes the Nation of Islam is a black
supremacist cult run by the leader Louis
Farrakhan it's actually a hate group
because the Nation of Islam is a a group
masquerading as a religion it's not
Islam the Westboro Baptist Church
they're not Baptists you know Knology
really but the Islam and the Church of
Scientology have joined together to make
this a group Oreo cookie where the Oreo
colors are flipped and the white part is
on the house
it's got this black chocolate destroy
the Nation of Islam like it's destroying
the Mormons and the Scientologists
should sell Louis Farrakhan is this Jew
hating black supremacist who has said
things in the past like they you know
criticizing the Jews for being Jews
major split in his cult and where women
dress up like poofy black nuns when you
see some of their big videos it's scary
when you see this auditorium in Detroit
just full of people there's one video
where they have Scientologists in one
area and he says things about you know
all white people are mentally ill but
white guy l ron hubbard he believed the
door suppressive persons who are you
know but like he's bounced off
scientology as they came to right so
this the nation of islam and a half
apparently and like people said like
what are you doing do you like we're
trying to be a dignified religion thing
here and you're like dealing with these
social outcasts the church of
scientology whose reputation is
radioactively money
yeah and they last now we have loose
Farah Khan's crew the Nation of Islam
partnering with the Church of
Scientology and you know that's nice for
this lot of speakers there and stuff
like then they advertise things like
probably few people go to but they the
Church of Scientology partnered with
them to promote to the churches lovely
properties in Inglewood and they're just
gorgeous delicious empty animal
fantastic it's really a shame whenever I
see any of their ideal orgs and they're
not being used because you know they
don't get a lot of people in there you
see the inside and they're just
beautiful like the architecture is
beautiful like look at all of that
wasted space and that wasted
they architecture firms that work for
them make a lot of money off buildings
that are never used and there's like an
infinite budget so for once these
architects are building some beige
suburban mall and I work with architects
to help them maintain and build those
walls and stuff but I know how you know
just painting them all can cost $150,000
oh yeah labor and the paints today can't
have poisonous stuff in them that makes
it look great
so they cost more and yet we these
architecture firms do a gig with the
Church of Scientology there's like no
expense spared like it would be a great
thing to put on the architecture firms
website as they can just hide the
scientology logo and does the church
also all these are the the companies
that do this work is that a way of
filtering the money back into their own
pockets things up a lot and they will do
stuff like put giant air conditioners at
the top of a building upside down yeah I
saw in the video that Nathaniel put up
about the Englewood organ he got into a
big camera fight with the black guy that
came out he was dressed as a
Scientologist I don't know if he was a
Scientologist or the workers there one
of the birth body routers okay
now probably for next to nothing now is
what's the actually Nation of Islam
dressed as Scientology or is that now
the same thing you know whatever you
crazy talking basically for free as a
slave at this place and they're promised
that every time someone comes in and
signs up for something they will get a
cut of it in a pyramid scheme type style
like my parents were in the amway and
that was the same thing we're like you
get people who do some work so you will
rise up to make more money without
having to do any yeah it's just weird
that you know that they're doing this to
black people too well
I feel like they wanted some really
great property and Inglewood and one of
them the Inglewood community center when
they bought it hosted a huge cellphone
tower the AT&T owns so people what
became the building in Inglewood is a
beautiful sort of a community theater
open space where like jazz bands by the
play you know once upon a time it has
like thing on top that draws people it's
not a church it just said hey this is a
public music place or whatever here we
are but it has cellphone towers on it
and so the church bought that and
there's this big page in the back full
of 18t equipment complete with like
battery backups and stuff that you know
AT&T is paying the money every month
just to use that building as the best
cellphone tower and that means the
church can probably use their sneaky
people to go in there and screw with the
system and get into AT&T network to do
whatever I don't know but they could do
things like spy on people who are using
cell phones an area or you know get into
18 T's network and spy on protesters who
have accounts with a teen teen because
they definitely do do that don't bend
it's weird whenever we opposed to show
about you we get three or four comments
about this is against the freedom of
religion and blah blah blah blah I'm
canceling my subscription with 13
o'clock
[Laughter]
he was on this video from grief over
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
some reason on the reddit posted
something that spilled over I got all
these views yeah which is great my
analytics because of a temporary spike
views like or view like something might
view link which is the most important
thing went down also tell that it wasn't
a standard aggregate both video because
it about very few comments yeah my
videos get fewer views but they get many
comments so there's people that are
engaged yeah and like a million people
watching a video and then just like
going away that's not as engaging as to
keep you on YouTube typing something
where you can see more ads and keep you
there instead of Facebook so so I could
tell that even though I don't get the
massive uses someone like who I I get
the audience involvement and I always
try and respond to interest in college
yeah hey tell everybody about happy
Smurf man he's a stripper died
a garry scarff was a long time
Scientologists he was born Mormon and he
died last year so I did a video bringing
that up he was born a Mormon and then he
became a Scientologist and he went into
OSA the secret police and he worked for
Kendrick Moxon their evil lawyer and a
bunch basically weren't a most evil part
of Scientology prolonged HUD and then
cyclopædia acknowledged of this soap
operas if he had like subscribed to the
guy versus you know 1980 or something
that's this intense value that I don't
have anymore you can just say oh that's
odo Huber some of his name is ermine his
sister's name I forget she the left and
he can't talk to her anymore so like
that's just odo Huber one of those cult
guards you can do that to all kinds of
people in spot them now can you believe
him because he was also a ridiculous
liar I mean he was as the Scientologists
have done hate videos on him he did lie
they paid him to lie they told him when
he was a Scientologist secret police to
lie about being involved in Jonestown a
group called the cult awareness Network
and as this covered about 60 minutes the
cult wareness Network ended up being
such a thorn in Scientology side that
they took it over and killed it
and speaking of killing it Smurf left
Scientology when they told him that they
wanted his help in murdering Cynthia
kisser the leader of the cult awareness
Network Anne and her child you ran away
was mortally offended and just scared
and he went to the FBI and he said I
have all this problems of dirt and stuff
and they said Oh talk about what
Scientology they're like oh whatever you
know yeah and so eventually when
anonymous happened in exactly ten years
ago the next month March will be my
tenure versity protesting the church he
went
there and protest it with people and did
stuff and he may at this point we met
you made me very educated may also make
me want to scream because he would be
nice to me in person then go online and
just beat venomous and like attacking
everyone and from all sides and play all
sides against each other and always
rejecting being held just a very
isolating thing HIV positive and gay so
you multiply being gay times more minute
on Scientology yeah that's a [ __ ] up
existence was just milking your
insecurities in order to use you right
yeah eventually he just could not lose
weight he would lose weight and he had
to lose weight to have a gastric bypass
there meanwhile is HIV I don't know how
well he was handling that because I'm
HIV positive and because of that
screw-up I can get free medical care and
it's you know otherwise it's like for
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
whatever no he would not and I wanted to
help him with his videos because he did
not know how to copy videos from his
camera into his computer and save them
so he would upload things to YouTube and
that was the only copy and then he'd
erased the chip into the court more
dance so he got into this thing where
first of all I lost my video channel in
2008 because YouTube was so picky about
it and was listening to son told you too
much they don't do that anymore
now I could almost do anything I'm not
getting America to just take it down
I lost my youtube channel in 2008 by not
doing anything that really violated
YouTube the church pressured them to
take my channel down so now my youtube
channel isn't YouTube / and gurgi Pope
is huge / the other side totally and
Smurfs make things worse because he
actually did violate YouTube's Terms of
Service by going to cult legal people
kendry moccasins house and in his house
and saying this is his house
shootin the house of some of their other
lawyers stuffing YouTube took his videos
down which caused the third demerit
which caused him to lose the whole
channel and guess what all those videos
he did got or their so yeah you know you
just posted a really good one that he
did a couple weeks back with him and
worried a frank Paulo trying to ask him
from wrong yeah that's a classic like
yeah I'm gonna encourage the audience to
go on your channel and go watch that
video because that's just classic
Scientologist behavior just constantly
was asking the same question over and
over and over
it's literally like some kind of a
religious inquisitions when I was around
them all the time I felt like I was just
gonna go mental I was like I get her
away from you people you're driving me
up to practice where we work it was a
publishing company yeah and you and they
were just like relentless and they're
questioning they knew I was in a
Scientologist and there were other
people that worked there just weren't
Scientologists I think but you know
after I was there for a while I was kind
of like I trust no one
so it went like that but they were just
one they were dumbest [ __ ] they didn't
know anything about anything
a lot of them were teenagers yeah stuff
like that like you say like you'd make
some cultural reference or some like
history reference that everybody knows
and they would just look at you like a
deer in the headlights like that now I
didn't know
basically once when it was like and they
were just I don't know I did there was
just something so weird and robotic
about me and anybody in the audience
that does not know who Scientology who
they are they're very dangerous and they
penetrated the FBI - everything was the
only cult that was able to do that now I
think they were I think they're I think
they were more dangerous in the past and
they are now I think during as a
weakened state but a cornered animal can
be very dangerous
yeah Waco Texas and then on the
anniversary of that P Murrah Building in
Oklahoma City which was a government
building so so they don't want to the
government and part is afraid of them
and yet they're really we keep it in a
lot of ways they're only going to hurt
themselves so we Miscavige what's gonna
shoot up with himself it's a bad cult of
I guess a week people masquerading as
excellent people and even and you have
to be a certain way in order to really
join Scientology I'd question your
sanity if you were to join Scientology
yeah if you're born into it and I really
I sympathize well that were born into it
they know if you join later than your
own [ __ ] that's on you right alright I
guess this is a good time to take a
break so we will be back in just a
minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back in here is the second
half of the interview with the angry gay
protesters in a fight with colt guard
Alexei on Hollywood yeah I don't post
yet but I will later this month with
legally good stuff what happened was
that two of these [ __ ] block protesters
these are people who go to anything from
a library to a Coast Guard Station to a
police station to a post office you just
poke their cameras at them and do what
the psychologists called a loud
investigation we are watching you just
to see what happens because you're
constitutionally allowed to do that just
like the people are allowed to chase
Paris Hilton or other celebrities with a
camera on the public street if things
can get bad when the people you're
watching have an overreaction they've
had a big reaction from Scientology news
[ __ ] block protesters have they've had a
big reaction from the federal prison
downtown where the guards there acted
like Scientologists we're throwing water
on protesters out the window I mean
federal employees yeah the scene is
Hollywood Boulevard in the hollywood
guaranty building which is Scientology's
for evil building it's like the Pentagon
where all the evil lawyers work and
right across the street is where all the
designers that work with all the
architecture firms to build their real
estate work so it's a super important
place and Alexi this Russian cold guard
remember I told you that you are
Russians yeah you fell guard he's been
there since at least 2008 probably must
be on that but in the video the
cock-block protesters who renamed
California Guardian and Ohio Guardian
one of these guys came all the way from
Cincinnati my hometown to protest them
and then gets arrested I said don't do
that that's why I don't go to Clearwater
California Guardian is like this frumpy
Quaker looking
Jewish guy so he's gonna play the bad
guy in the story and then
Guardian for my hometown this is
straight super handsome guy so he's
gonna play the great guy they're both in
Alexis face are they trying their camera
in his face and I'm like oh don't do
that because it makes them a victim and
it's playing into their hands and then
Alexi pulls out his industrial-strength
hundred and fifty dollar mega flashlight
and blasts them in the face then they
start hustling and Alexa he gets his
flashlight taken away then they all go
running into the street start chop-socky
[Laughter]
the police arrive and there Ohio
Guardian throws the flashlight in the
trash and they're at work but I was
other court meetings for them and this
can be devastatingly expensive Ohio
Guardian has to pay for a plane flight
out here every time just to go to a
court meeting that the results of which
might be continuing for you actually
just do this again we haven't done
anything you know continue which means
continue the case to the next date when
everyone can get together and talk about
it sounds very expensive just to show up
there and then there's the expense of
the lawyer to end they are not religious
leaders like I am my world which means a
pro bono vexatious litigant which means
he works for free and he loves to sue
people too much they're important with
the cop block lawyer lady
her husband is a paralegal and he was
the heavyset guy on the bicycle in this
game video yeah right he was the one who
like throw people off feels like the
Scientologists have bite guards and he
was like the bite guard Anonymous these
guys are in court and Moxon shows up and
cracks Ashlee and the Moxon has
contacted their lawyer they have a court
date later this month after that I'll
release the video but Moxon the church's
legal authorities one of their he's not
the most powerful lawyer he's in some
ways sometimes just a glorified
paralegal but he's been with them a
million years he knows where all the
bodies are buried very important you
know Wikipedia page Jews over 16 as he
is usually put in charge of dealing with
anonymous or protest Internet protesters
like that so now they don't have
anonymous they have a couple of guys who
I don't care about holding signs or
having masks or making a party out of it
they just care about staring at you
computer from 2002 space office and you
are being watched and they once again
it's the Hawthorne effect that people's
behavior changes when they know they're
being watched and nasty Nathaniel was
body slammed by the more obeyed Chief of
Police recently doing that and don't get
me started
my fellow protester and ultra boy nasty
Nathaniel he's he's got a case he can
pick them over major get financial even
supposed he was supposed to come on but
we didn't hear back from him he wanted
to come on yeah that's right he was just
fighting with the church you know like
Street refused over a flashlight thing
which now you know the beauty of my
protests we're the only thing that gets
hurt are pansies I talk too loud outside
one of them what happened with you
playing the ass forever what happened
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
anywhere on a Friday I'm gonna go to the
judge and bring this up because I want
to like his power to do that dropped
over the West your and it drags for King
seven in court went to benefit just my
word for free I want to do as a
protester as protesters by you know
those guys have to pay for and then so
Kendrick Moxon besides he's come to drop
all charges only thing it like
restraining order against or whatever
like and like since one of them Ellucian
Ohio it's like not a big deal so they're
gonna go to court at the end of the
month and after that I will release the
video cuz I don't want to release it now
because it just messes up the kiddos
it's the jurors over if it will be it'll
make a great video but the great thing
is that Moxon cave ends the church say
caved and they just don't want to do the
problems they just want it to go away
which is totally not how I'll run over
said to do it on Hubbard said sue runs
hers to death
that's probably what would happen me
because they know I have nowhere else to
go right these protesters could just as
easily be protesting a post office or a
military base so they want them to go
away but me I'm like a parasite that
just moves on them only you know like
like one of those fish that lives up the
but that's what's just great to see
their lawyers cry yeah that is pretty
awesome nothing at I'm in a GB what's
the state of the cold man anything new
[Laughter]
even though they Trump people in from
everywhere else to they open two of them
this week but this past week or two one
in Salt Lake City Mormon Territory and
one and someone sent me a video of that
and one in there's two Pacific Northwest
so or no listen maybe another country
who can tell but their openings which
used to be this fanfare things you
probably get the Chief of Police to show
up now it's like they can they barely
even promote they can force people to go
to them if you're in the bubble when
you're outside the bubble is harder to
find out about them and they don't have
Chiefs of Police talking up their things
anymore they have like you know the the
Commissioner of the parks that's a sign
that's a sign they're not KSW they're
boiling down into the little bubble and
they have very few super rich donors
left except for the totally black melt
like Tom Cruise he and these
celebrities RNA as it tightens and
tightens just with each passing day it's
more likely I was gonna blow up the
latest thing was this actor named Danny
Masterson who was on that 70s show
otherwise if you didn't watch that to
show you don't you know who he is but he
shows up at there I hate psychiatrist
events and things like that I mean like
I'm such a great guy
look at me talking to you psychiatry
haters well you got caught raping
multiple women and when they they were
so obviously went to their own church
just for help they were rebuffed and now
the FBI which has been dragging their
feet on the case because the fence
almost crushes them to drop it you sure
the FBI bringing like do you know life
imprisonment level charges against it
apparently so that's going to be a fun
thing to watch this year because if he
gets life in prison who cares he's just
another scummy rapist like however you
want you know Bill Cosby right but the
government can also say you
Scientologists so you have your own you
know judicial system and when they went
to it you ignored them and yet this is
everything that actually happened so the
government could if they wanted to
possibly screw in the church that way
and say you know you were religious
system is a failure endeavor you're not
real injured or something like that I
mean I'm not saying that going to the
FBI is famous for even alone and science
all mr. major Trump supporters at the
moment Donald Trump hasn't terminated
the Washington bureaucracy to such a
point a to strive to bite him you know
psychology which I deal with camera what
it wasn't sense yeah yeah what happened
with Marty you know Marty yeah a major
psychologist who turned against them and
his white suit that he was spied on so
badly that his wife sued the church
saying ok you can spy on him because
that's true that's a religious thing as
he's a Scientologist and your religion
says you should spy on but I was never
as I told you shouldn't be spying on me
putting cameras and birdhouses following
us everywhere
harassing us in public making banners on
our torch right she sued them and the
lawyers spent a ton of money working for
free even though they're not
unlike mine who worked for Rico's I'm a
religious leader but and all these
lawyers on the case and it was going
really well it was getting really close
to David Miscavige need to pose the
great leader and David Miscavige was not
ever reposed which means a deposition is
illegal in him you have to tell the
truth just as if you were the court aid
why me
so the church approached Marty and his
wife and just gave them a pile of money
yeah I didn't know what had happened
yeah now sir what happened now he's out
talking trash about behind Leah Remini
is new show why'd you pay money money
whereas like obviously the breath is to
be paid off to shut up and then they let
their lawyers in the lurch and said all
that working for a man don't care where
I paid the lawyers have thought about
suing them because you don't want to
make lawyers maybe we're working for you
on for free worked so hard on that just
to be used which is what Scientologists
do anyway so whether Bernie's in
Scientology or not whether it's Murph
since I told you or not they act that
way yeah you know don't take this the
wrong way because I know you know a lot
of X x ologist i've been if you follow
them long enough online and see what
they say and you watch then they don't
make any goddamn sense below i think it
messes a mom and this
for ten years it's gonna like take 10
years to be out of it to be on
brainwashed like it was a Jenna
Miscavige Hill who wrote a book about
Eva nice he said it took me a couple of
years stop asking people if I could turn
the lights on slaves born into it yeah
so if you're in it for 30 years you know
you're not gonna live long enough to
completely are great right yeah I do
definitely feel like even even the ones
that have the channel like you know
Marty bronzer was in and even ones that
have been out for a while the longer
they're in the more messed up they seem
like yes you would probably know this
best having worked with yeah yeah there
are Scientologists who won't hire see
organization for mercy work workers see
organization it is their priesthood and
there are I read in one of the books
Jenna Miscavige Hills both she said I
was working for this place to hire me
because workers because they're all you
know I mean I can't say
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Clym graphical presentation
Oh Tony Ortega put up a thing that I'm
going to use and I printed out pictures
from twenty other fingers blog and show
them to him but his family when they
were still together and happy and he
reacts in true Scientology's fashion by
acting like a robot man and I put the
paper on the ground and then Angel comes
out later grabs the paper roses yeah I
tell you well so all I have this video
called the wash
I haven't finished four in a long time
with nasty Nathaniel my Ultra boy going
to golden era productions and they meet
you police officers who have pretty nice
things to say about Scientology so it's
kind of a video game battle debate which
one is right the frumpy protesters or
the sexy there's no winners but it's
raining and it's very rare to see rain
at Riverside or this place it's all
green and beautiful and it's raining the
whole time like the cops shirt gets wet
I don't know if you can see your nipples
through it because it's actually an area
of gold base that got washed out because
there's such a dangerous place to be
with floods earthquakes landslides
liquefaction and even the water that the
Cyclops blew their own water with their
own sewage system there's a new big area
washing down and this debate between the
cops and protesters they're both right
and they're both wrong so it's a wash
and then nasty Nathaniel goes to the
Panda Express down the road and two
police cars follow them to try try and
sit in the parking lot watching from the
day before the Christmas parade I don't
know if I'm going to do anything from
the Christmas parade I put the good
parts of that up in pieces but then
there's also some guy phosphate from
November I'm going to put out
I'm slow to be editing these things
because I it just drives me crazy to do
this low for each video and yet over
time they're fine but yeah it's really
in the morning to like saying I don't
know my coworker punched in the face and
it only gets two thousand views and it
was the moral make Shiva Police who do
an annual this cop block people they get
big dude she gets like twenty thousand
uses like the others there's a much
bigger audience for people who know what
cops are and don't like that yeah wanna
see cops and turbulator of course
everybody else's videos are Hollywood
style mine are Hollywood style so they
have more of an evergreen quality you
know well you did that for a living
you're in pro right yes because Leah
Remini show my first Emmy Award was
animating the Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks's HBO series the Pacific
miniseries that discuss the lives of our
nation's veterans World War two that was
like a really boring thing I couldn't
see it working on so we seem like such a
nice guy it was all it was take objects
from high-definition objects for video
games and up residence of movie quality
and then the whole production pipeline
demanded that all the images be like
this aqua color so you're going to
animate everything in this weird aqua
color so when it comes out the other end
it's going to look like 1940s crow -
crow yeah the show had problems on its
first episode and it's chronological so
you can't like move episodes around so
they had to stop everything to redo the
first episode so the special effects
supervisor had time to go after every
shot it just rearranged each glowing
bullet hole tracer fire yeah and every
time you do that my boss loses money
because I have to go back and suddenly
fix something that's not broken so
the enemy award is great it's kind of a
career issue but for what I am I hated
the project is like windless go away and
like then I while I'm analyzing it like
I'm watching my stunt man's head explode
and it doesn't mean anything to me but
then I looked online at a chart of
Japanese battleships and I thought boy
they should hit a lot of battleships and
then I realize wait that's a chart of
the classes of battleships so every name
on there is maybe a hundred ships and I
thought they did that in 1920 I mean how
many Japanese children starved to death
because they were building up a war
machine that exploded eventually like I
wanted to cry for Leah Remini show but
it won an Emmy also and my contributions
that was like pictures of concentration
camps and spikes and things that no one
else has and if they've taken my stuff
out of it you were lost like 1% of the
image time but that was the percent went
to here this cabbage his father was
talking about the concentration camp be
sitting and then wake up to my
photograph which has been a thorn in
Davis cabbage aside since 2009 otherwise
the show would have been they couldn't
even afford two reenactments so
otherwise the show is very heartfelt
talking heads on the tripod yeah yeah so
I'm really glad to have contributed that
kind of dynamic stuff to life you know
Leah Remini spread stamens yeah we just
black department might just get to kick
him in the balls
it's funny there's so many I mean a spy
that you mentioned the concentration
camps everything Scientology has these
secret bases and some one of them was a
vanilla death and guards
yeah and evidently guys that have worked
there going crazy and blow their own
heads off it's it's got a bunch of
tablets of Elrond Hubbard's writings and
furry team any bar listeners that don't
really know what Scientology is it's
it's kind of like a 1950's montage I
find my control that has elements of an
apocalyptic world since everything you
race is perfect radiation told you even
though it is a biography they'll run
hover because the [ __ ] wants to listen
him talk about owner neutrons or
whatever I tried to read part of it it's
mostly about mind control it is nothing
to don't make sense it makes you car sir
I don't read a bunch of stuff when I
worked at that place and it's like his
writing is atrocious
yeah what's weird is that there's a lot
of parallels between Scientology and
juichi which is the philosophy that
drives North Korea yes
totalitarian states family and they're
they're like family mobster takeover of
North Korea
other things with is Stalinism yeah it's
not as bad as Hitler fascism in terms of
eating people up and spitting them out
but it's still bad enough it's like
Stalinism is more sustainable because
it's not quite as aggressive in terms of
its using people still you know
thousands of people under Stalin where
we're incarcerated if you specially if
you have skills if you're born into it
yeah it's just messes people up so much
I really have a lot of admiration for
people in a stadium because how would
you even conceive of it yeah after being
raised under such a system and nothing
is weird about these totalitarian
systems that are constantly in this kind
of apocalyptic defensive stance and
what's what's weird is that if the
apocalypse did actually happens North
Korea and Scientology probably would
survive everybody else would probably
die there's the systems are just like
almost like trilobite they're so
primitive and so simple that they take
their already collapsed you can't
collapse North Korea any more than it
all right yes they're bomb-proof because
there's nothing to destroy this will
actually probably go up on Tuesday maybe
up on Tuesday yeah yeah I'm sure we'll
hear from we always soccers yeah
I can say something stupid to get these
copper protesters in trouble or me
something stupid to like get myself in
trouble over these just taking orders
like groups there were six we can always
send easily my lawyer took them any
individual charges hurts them all to one
class action well we can always send you
an edited copy so you can check it if
you want with this implies it's straight
and then we can go ahead and you know no
thanks she's gotten better or I don't
like what you put up or stays up too
long because she had like an incredibly
long amount of time ago I can enhance
that we could put it into Film Fest so
yeah that'd be on something so you still
it's not like YouTube where I'm totally
concerned with the length of time people
watch something it varies between four
to eight minutes on my videos because
you can watch anything or do anything on
the internet or with the computer you
can actually put it down and go for a
walk outside people should not be
disturbed and turn off their phones and
sit and look at the screen yeah it's
definitely a much better environment for
them so do you still do any contract
somebody with somebody needed some
animation virgin animating an episode
that highlighted literacy where I
animated books coming out of the wall
and they have magical sparkles that
flutter around Jane the Virgin girl is
in a flashback where she learns the
importance of reading especially
just a masturbate over here first where
they kiss in a window and the windows
open and petals blow in Phoebe flutter
around the virgin show is deliberately
partner show that's not trying to be
realistic so something goofy can happen
and it's like you know all in close
cover yeah yeah you know any episode
minute so how could somebody contact you
if they wanted to do a project with you
or something like that is right there on
amber get probe number and now Hoss
patreon I'm doing for you 300 and 400
dollars in patronage a month which is
good it's slowly building but I needs it
like I need to get more involved in
things like promoting myself you guys
and other stuff and I was thinking of
going to I live right off the Sunset
Strip that's like the coolest place in
the world I mean I could play the Grand
Theft Auto video game it's a virtual
version of my own liquor store and the
street is the comedy store more people
like Richard Pryor and Robin Williams
and others got their start at 70 who's
been going strong ever since I might as
well go there and just kind of snoop
around the tens of shows and then
possibly go up on open mic night or
whatever after talk to the people there
and I also want to meet Joe Rogan there
because he's had some Scientologist on
his show I want to say thank you so much
for doing there see you do an agpa I
could really see you coming out with a
dead ball channel I try to find the dead
balls and defunct businesses and you do
a whole video show how a company would
rise into out into existence and fall
like there's a guy named dan Bell that
does it he does a great one about dead
moms very funny but like the malls that
this company that I work for has are
like functional but there's a lot of
malls especially enclosed around the
country that are we failed yeah going to
the Internet or people just don't want
to go to that particular law alright cuz
that's way too many oh yes something
over bald is that the problem okay well
is there anything else that you wanted
to tell us before you poor you sign off
happy partisan on this issue we need to
focus on the cult that was a fun show
that was a GP in his true form and
please if you'd like to support his
cause trying to get rid of Scientology
and turbulator the Scientologists trying
to get trying to get people to leave
trying to discourage new people from
joining yeah which I think he's been
pretty effective and doing it the whole
idea is just to put awareness of what
science our awareness out there to what
Scientology is what it will probably do
to you yeah don't don't get involved
with that yeah the people who are born
into it or unlucky enough if you ask me
only a lunatic would join that group
yeah and it has to be a rich lunatic
yeah anyway because they just want your
money honestly I really the worst do I
feel the worst for is people who were
born into it didn't have a choice yeah
and I really have to say and I think I
said this during the interview but like
I really admire people who were raised
in it mica Jenna Miscavige Hill yeah it
was actually the niece of the big the
big bad in Scientology like the
the whole thing and she actually got the
[ __ ] out of there it heard a book about
her experiences it is horrifying yeah so
you know I really admired that she had
the stands to do that and all the people
that have gotten out that have been in
there for such a long yeah that coat
will never go away
it won't go away by force what will
happen is it's just gonna become
unpopular it'll kind of lay low and
slowly just kind of shrink ya know just
already happen that's already happening
so Scientologists are kind of delusional
will hunt down enemies so they're
destroying the church they're destroying
the church man the church is already
destroyed yeah it's just shrinking yeah
you know it's over them going after
people like a cheapy is really kind of a
waste of their time yeah the damage has
already been done and they don't did
most of the day so if they didn't suck
so much yeah if they just get mad when
people tell the truth about them and
they're like stop you stopping people
from joining the church I'm like no you
guys are doing that because of you
sucking so much if LRH Tech was really
what they claimed it to be the church
would have grown by leaps and bounds
that we've been successful yeah but
because of the policies that LRH put
into the church an integral part of the
church the church failed Church failed
because of LRH and the tech yeah yeah
sorry that's how it doesn't work so
anyway I hope you enjoyed episode 80 and
like I said go check out WWJ poke calm
he's also got a YouTube channel called
the end of Scientology and he's got a
patreon so go and give him some support
if you like what he does he's got a lot
of really funny videos you should go and
check them out also if you'd like to
support our show we also have a patreon
at 13 o'clock podcast and if you don't
like patreon I would like to perhaps
give a one-time donation that would be
very nice you could go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress comm and
there is a link in the sidebar to a
patreon account also remember to check
out our zazzle store which is Azle calm
slash 13 o'clock then we have some
various t-shirts on there that you can
purchase if you'd like to advertise the
show that would be cool too they have
cool designs on it too oh and check out
our latest movie review which was the
black hole yeah at 79 the only PG rated
Disney movie up until that time so
that'll do it for this week's episode
see you next Tuesday bye
thank you for listening
I write just for you but others hearing
this man
things they were argued
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you